rarement le palais de justice d'ottawa
n'avait vu un tel déploiement les
caméras sur le qui vive pour capter ce
moment mcdecaux sorti de l'ombre pour
faire face à la justice
loquace comme sénateur vedette des
conservateurs le voilà silencieux au
banc des accusés
nous dirons ce que nous avons à dire
devant la cour affirme son avocat de
glace durant la lecture des 31 chefs
d'accusation qui pèsent contre lui mike
deux filles a plaidé non coupable
il est seul ici comme si on lui
demandait de rendre des comptes pour
tous les péchés du sénat fait valoir son
avocat dans l'aude bayne ils plaident
que mcdo fille a été entraînée de force
dans l'engrenage des tactiques du bureau
du premier ministre qui voulait étouffer
la faire et qu'il a capitulé sous la
pression intenable donné joe wright et
son entourage
et voilà qu'il lève le voile sur des
détails inédits invoque en entrevue à la
grc
nigel wright a expliqué que le 22
février 2013
il a clairement informé le premier
ministre du stratagème pour que mike
deux filles rembourse nous sommes en
litige plaide qu'il s'agissait d'une
erreur
le tout serait coordonné avec des lignes
de presse un jour à intérêt aussi
reconnu qu'il s'apprêtait à forcer la
main des membres du caucus sous
rembourser des frais auxquels ils
avaient peut-être droit juste pour
tourner la page sur le scandale si ce
stratagème que stephen harper aurait
autorisé le jour même et c'est dans ce
contexte donc que mike deux filles
auraient accepté le fameux chèque de 90
mille dollars de nigel wright la
couronne plaide plutôt que la preuve
établira que le sénateur était au moins
un partenaire à part entière dans cet
arrangement voire même l'instigateur
ça c'est pour l'accusation de corruption
quant à toutes les autres de fraude et
d'abus de confiance
il n'est pas nécessaire de compliquer
indûment les choses fait valoir le
procureur marc crosms il était
impensable dit il pour le sénateur de
filles de se faire payer des frais de
logement dans sa propre maison à ottawa
en faisant passer son chalet de l'île du
prince édouard pour une résidence
principales armes et des agendas
électroniques du maïdo fille il tentera
de démontrer comment celui-ci organisait
des rencontres à l'extérieur pour faire
payer par le sénat des voyages
personnels comme pour aller à la
première de sa fille au théâtre l'avocat
de mailles des filets compte que son
client n'a fait que respecter les règles
du sénat aussi archaïque soit elle le
sénateur deux filles avaient un rôle
sénatoriales unique dès sa nomination
laisse entrevoir dans notre bayne
aujourd'hui du moins le premier ministre
harper se montre et perturbe à bhl nous
allons continuer à offrir toute l'aide
possible à leur couronne parce qu'avec
monsieur d'affirmer attention lance
l'avocat de mme avec deux filles ou du
stade ce n'est que le début
ouais manuel pour tenter de faire
acquitter son client l'avocat de mike
duffy va tenter faire valoir que c'était
la culture politique de l'époque tout le
monde on agit c'est un peu comme ça oui
c'est la céline que ce procès criminel
devient un procès politique vous voyez
parce que en effet pour faire accuser
maiden pour faire acquitter mcafee dans
un bain et nuit accuse tout le sénat
faisant valoir que les règles sont
tellement vague finalement tout est
permis c'est pas un enjeu de savoir si
les dépenses au moral éthique ou quoi
que ce soit que vous prenez porte quoi
peut passer pour une dépense
sénatoriales que la même logique thiel
pour des contrats que manque de filles
aux données qui ont fini par payer faut
dire un entraîneur une maquilleuse donc
rien là pour redorer l'image du sénat
sur tout et on l'a entrevue d'une
certaine façon aujourd'hui l'avocat de
mike de fives a non seulement vouloir
faire le procès l'entourage du premier
ministre
mais de stephen harper lui même d'une
certaine façon en faisant valoir qu'il a
autorisée toute l'opération camouflage
de ce scandale et jusqu'à quel point
stephen harper doit s'inquiéter des
révélations qui pourraient être
embarrassantes pour lui mais je voudrais
que le pari des conservateurs c'est que
stephen harper a déjà d'une certaine
façon payer le prix politique qui avait
à payer pour cette affaire là qui est en
train de s'en remettre que l'intérêt des
canadiens va s'étioler d'autant plus que
l'on une journée spectaculaire mais
c'est un pro cette fraude
ça va rentrer dans le détail ce
pas toujours aussi palpitant le risque
en même temps c'est qui va des nouveaux
documents des nouvelles révélations et
qu'on va voir cette affaire leur sous un
nouveau jour d'un procès qui s'annonce
long dont 41 jours car selon être le
times etc
merci beaucoup emmanuel au revoir au
revoir et justement pour en savoir
davantage sur ce scandale au sénat et
notamment sur ses acteurs clés je vous
invite à consulter notre dossier web à
l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran